the taliban announced a caretaker
cabinet for their keenly awaited
government for afghanistan the
announcement comes more than three weeks
after the hardline group took the
capital kabul unopposed
and u.s led troops pulled out of the
country the taliban have pledged to
establish what they say would be an
inclusive government
and we can take you now to kabul
afghanistan for these breaking
developments ali latifi is joining us
from the capitol ali we just heard about
some key positions for a new caretaker
government who stood out for you
i mean one of the things that stood out
was the omission
[Music]
was not on the list and he is the leader
of the taliban as far as we know he is
the second longest serving leader of the
taliban so it raises questions
about rumors that have been circulating
for quite a while that he may not be
alive uh why wasn't he named
uh the head of this uh taliban
administration when we had met with
taliban officials
a couple weeks ago they insisted that he
would be coming to kabul that he's very
much alive that he has been in
afghanistan all this time and yet now
he's nowhere to be found on the list
now a lot of people are also talking
about uh sarah judin haqqani what can
you tell us about him
he's the leader of the khani network
which is considered
to be the most violent and brutal
segment of the taliban
usually in the past when they were
really horrific suicide attacks and
other kinds of attacks
when the government would release its
findings the former government they
would say that it was the haqqani
network behind them and the haqqani men
have been known to be
the most fierce the most brutal
the most violent uh faction within the
taliban all this time
and him being the interior minister
will raise a lot of questions especially
now that protests are picking up around
the country
and it's also a very interesting choice
because in terms of the international
community which you know some countries
have said they need to engage with the
taliban it's going to be very difficult
to engage with somebody who used to be
part of the haqqani network
well right and most of these men and
they're all men
um the one thing that they did do is
that they did include tajiks and
turkmens and non-pashtuns within their
government uh yes most of these men uh
are on some kind of a terrorist list or
some kind of a un
uh travel sanction list so it will be
interesting to see how the rest of the
world engages with them now of course
now that they have a government
um you know to to the avalon people you
know one thing that is very much
important is is financial reengagement
with this country because we still have
you know banks where people are waiting
hours and hours in line
to you know just try and take out any
amount of money i myself today when i
when for instance when i went to take
out money from western union they were
like well we can give it to you in
avalonies but we can't give it to you in
dollars and you have to come back you
know a few hours later when we get the
money we're waiting for from the central
bank so um you know it's very important
to the avon people that
some kind of financial re-engagement
begins but of course for the rest of the
world it'll be difficult because
the people that they're trying to deal
with almost all of them are in some kind
of a terror list
that is very striking indeed do we know
how long this caretaker cabinet will be
in place and what follows i mean are we
expecting elections to take place in
afghanistan
uh they have as far as i know they
haven't said anything about some kind of
an expiration date about it and i think
part of why
they rush to announce this is one you
know for for the economy because as long
as there is for instance no minister of
finance or minister foreign affairs
people who work in these places cannot
return to work and if they cannot return
to work they can't get a wage uh and the
economy has taken a huge dive over the
last three weeks the other thing is it's
a way to not make them seem weak or
disorganized you know it's a way for
them to say you know we have established
some kind of a cabinet until we have
something more formal and official uh to
go by
and this comes of course on a day where
we see people in kabul especially you
know they're still keeping up the
pressure on the taliban there have been
uh protests taking place what more can
you tell us about that
so there were several protests in the
city today some had you know a few dozen
some had a few hundred and in the larger
ones and the ones that that that
numbered in the hundreds possibly in it
you know more than a thousand uh we saw
that the taliban were very much shooting
into the air where uh you know trying to
disperse their crowds the crowds in
violent and uh aggressive manners um you
know people i spoke to said that they
had uh that they had suffered injuries
or they knew people had suffered
injuries and that they had taken injured
people to the hospital um but everyone i
spoke to said that they will continue to
hold these protests and that they will
not be silenced because they want to
make sure that their voices are heard
especially at this time even with the
taliban
increasing all of this pressure and as i
said earlier the prospect of sarajuddin
you know being the interior minister
which would put him in charge of
reacting to these sorts of things
uh ali latifi reporting from kabul on
those breaking developments for now
thank you very much
thank you
and as ali has been reporting a taliban
face little military opposition when
they reconquered afghanistan but as ali
just told this opposition among
civilians remains let's find out more
about the anti-taliban protests earlier
in kabul
a taste of what resisting the taliban
looks like
[Applause]
men with guns attempting to silence the
men and women armed with their voices
the hundreds of afghans who took to
kabul streets could not match the
taliban's shore force
the islamic government is shooting at
our people
they're very unjust they're not human at
all
they do not give us the right to
demonstrate
they're not muslims but infidels
[Applause]
as you can see what a situation we're in
[Music]
it's a situation these protesters may
have seen coming but it didn't stop them
from coming out to demand freedom for
women and more freedom for all
a right they say the taliban curtails
initially afghanistan's new law
enforcers had only watched passively
we're not here protesting to gain
something or to find a job in some
office we're here to protect the blood
of the youth we're here for our country
our land
another pocket of defiance has been
located north of kabul in the panshir
valley where the national resistant
force insists it is still standing
despite the taliban's claims of victory
in the region
the taliban's predominant control of
afghanistan is not in question but the
signs are that it faces a more resolute
public on its return to power
you